[Musique]
tu as mangé tous les jours même pas tous
les jours mais très souvent parce que
c'est la chose la plus facile à retenir
qu'on dit toi vincent tu en manges me
coûte moi j'en mange un peu moins mais
de temps à autres l'homme les nouilles
et spontanés se prépare en quelques
minutes on ajoutant tout simplement un
peu d'eau chaude
elles sont très populaires auprès des
jeunes on me dit de langue coin une
place où il ya des nouilles pas cher on
peut acheter
mais on ne me sion goudé par neuf mesnil
a lieu toutes les cases mandic l'école
en étant visiblement ces nouilles ne
plaisent pas qu'aux jeunes ici l
épicerie asiatique kim phat on a
l'impression d'être au royaume de la
nouilles instantanées pression' ans que
je rangeais complète cette couche ima
nutritionniste d'origine japonaise a
analysé plusieurs produits pour nous que
les nouilles instantanées c'est souvent
free mais quand c'est fabrice et quand
il ya au niveau de valence receive c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant si on voit la
balle et nutritive et que ça dépasse mes
temps 40 po fond de gras saturés c'est
sûr que c'est free à ok autre indice que
des nouilles ont été fritz et la
présence de l'huile de palme souvent
bien au delà liste d'ingrédients
regardant la quantité de sodium
mais ces 5 4 comme dans tout produit
transformé la quantité de sodium est
très élevée on s'en doutait mais
peut-être pas à ce point au yoyo 96 %
des apports martial 2300 mg de sodium
portion
selon santé canada pour rester en santé
les canadiens devraient viser 1500 mg de
sodium par jour juste dans ce bol on en
a deux mille 150 mg
[Musique]
dans les autres amis de mettre plus de
services et les salles où tous les sens
[Musique]
on voit que vous êtes
les connaisseurs mais fine bouche c'est
pas toi là ils sont tous lui mais en
fait vu par exemple mais juste un
emballage fait déjà moins permet selon
elle avec le bol il s'achète pas quitté
c'est pas très écologique c'est vrai on
trouve aussi une grande quantité de
nouilles instantanées dans tous les
supermarchés
plusieurs marques saveurs type de
contenant et tous contiennent trop de
sodium la liste des ingrédients et pour
c'est très très longue pour tous les
produits donc c'est quand même les
produits ultra transformer c'est que il
ya même des ingrédients qu'on ne connaît
pas ce coup c'est fait que c'est comme
on peut dire que c'est quand même assez
cynique et malgré les présentations sur
les contenants ces bols sont loin d'être
des repas complets de deux lames à 2 g
de protéines par un produit et que c'est
comme si vraiment pas beaucoup au japon
on mange tout le monde mange les
nouilles s'est pas seulement pour les
jeunes qui ne savent pas cuisiner et que
quand tu mets ton samedi en après midi
quand un enfant utilisé
ni instantanée mais on y ajoute toujours
des sources de protéines on ajoute
mettons en oeuvre soit on n'a jamais dit
ça si on ajoute des légumes pour que ce
soit plus nutritives quand je cuisine je
dis seulement la moitié de paquets
d'assaisonnement comme ça ça donne oui
ça donne à peu près 50% le var à
quotidienne mais c'est moi mon sale et
que ce qui est qu' on essaie de ne pas
boire tout le bouillon parce que le
sodium plus pâle soleil on se trouve
dans le bouillon fait comme on dit tu
dis souvent à mes enfants de ne pas voir
tout bouilhou il ya des restaurants
aussi qui font des ramen qu'il s'absente
plus à sa fille c'est comme dire amen
plus au dialogue
au japon on en mange partout sur la rue
c'est devenu aussi très populaire chez
nous comme ici celle à manille chine
pour le chef d' ipad
on est loin de l'instantanéité
ses cris pendant 8 à 12 heures qu'est ce
qu'il ya là dedans
oui à des biens les à ce légume par la
suite fred ses secrets mais toutes les
erreurs sont là dedans oui et après ça
on acheter du soya ou maisons c'est ce
bouillon filtrer qui sert de base à
toutes les soupes servies ici entre
chauffeurs les lieux et on mélange avec
notre la signature de maison rouge et
blanc apprécié à acheter le soupçon caso
on a eu chaud jusqu'à la trappe et
tremper un super show qui a récemment
versé dans bab avec des lots à chaque
différents pouillon on a un différend
noïd au bois pour la compagnie
[Musique]
viande tofu légumes est différente bat
ici les soupes ramène sont des repas
copieux et complet les gens qui viennent
ici qui sont d'origine japonaise ce
quitteront que vont nous ramène
ressemblons sur traditionnels oui
vraiment je décris un même qui était
j'allais au japon bon vénétie et hillion
souviens bien l'avion pour aller au
japon pour les nouilles instantanées
achetés au supermarché
l'intérêt premier demeure le prix on a
payé entre 33 cents et 5 $ 49 par
portion et en plus on prend de sympathie
4,99
il y en a par des individus à
l'intérieur c'est vrai que ça fait
partie de la popularité est ce à cause
des prix il vole un peu plus à peu près
tout les modèles mais ça varie les prix
en général et les 75 puis les autres les
pubs sont jeunes et 25 des pages en mer
du nord
sipa chaque équipe est un peu un gros
budget ce dîner avec ce sale sale fait
ça fait la job mais c'est pas aussi
n'existe aucun bogey
[Musique]